are these the details I gave you just
wrap it up look like it's the question
yeah okay good
figures thread tricks excellent shift
city okay just in case maybe you were
catching up let's just do this from
scratch okay we can work this out this
is defined by a nice equation okay
because that's what the eccentricities
it's that ratio okay so to make things a
little easier for us to work now I'll
just Chuck that over the other slide so
I have to do it fractions so I have a
distance formula on this side and I have
a perpendicular distance for God on this
side let's quickly compute it okay what
do I get on the left-hand side I swear
okay good that's fine two times what
absolute value of X minus one where did
that come from
that came from this in general form
right it's pretty easy so that's why I
don't need to be writer all divided by
well when you do the square root of a
squared plus B squared here your a and B
are going to be zero one so you actually
just get one there don't you so I should
actually write it just because that's
the full formula okay good now
it's great a lot okay I might as well
expand this while I'm at it
what do I get here
- becomes a four and then this is going
to become x squared minus 2x
that's a terrible - okay happy sigh huh
okay let's expand this out so far so
good
okay any suggestions I can simplify this
in a number of ways
what want I to be working toward watch
like what kind of last line do I want
what do you think should have on the
right-hand side we want the constants on
the right hand side yeah that's what
we've been working out so far so rented
space here the constants here I've got a
16 and a 4 so I'm getting minus 12
okay now what gathered everything else
on the left so let's see what I've got
for X quick here and one of them there
so I have my I've got a X and I have 8x
again negative 8x from both sides okay
so then I have a Y swim
okay now you told me just now
you wanted one on this side right so if
I divide through by minus twelve I'm
gonna get egg spread on four - does that
check out okay now what is this thing it
is very close to an ellipse isn't it
which I suppose we want to expect cuz we
started all this question lives but it
ain't ellipse hockey tell something else
is going on now immediately you can tell
it's not an ellipse but there's a domain
restriction going on because there's an
even power why okay so let's go ahead
and work out what the domain restriction
will be and then we'll give us some
clues I want this guy to be the subject
once I know he's the subject everything
else has to be positive
okay watch minus y squared on 12 kick
this guy over - yeah I probably want
this to be positive
okay great now forget about the 12th for
a second because really can you see the
12 doesn't make a difference to whether
it's positive or negative
it just makes it a bigger positive or a
bigger negative more negative so
therefore this thing here has to be
greater than or equal zero otherwise
this doesn't exist we'll stop for real
values anyway so Y can say the domain
will be defined by this guy being
greater than equal zero you're happy
with that otherwise it doesn't exist so
multiply through by some nicer numbers
like what's this look like it's down
minus four which means the roots are
- - and okay so therefore the actual
domain is where that thing is positive
or or equal to zero namely this part and
so now we know if domain is how would
you write X is less than or equal to
minus two or the other side
okay there's the domain now by the way
one of the reasons why I started with
this is kind of an unusual place to
start but it immediately tells you you
can't exist in here right so there's not
much point looking for a y-intercept
because there isn't one it can't exist
at x equals zero that's outside the
domain so I can't find a y-intercepts
what can I find that will help me work
out the shape of this thing I can work
out an x-intercept all right how do I do
that your y equals zero where shall I
put it I can fit one equals zero that
tells me x squared on for 's equal to
one
for so that already tells you - two
which are the very edges of that domain
those are intercepts okay how else work
out what this thing
reflected values plug-in masters did
anyone do that I'm interested because
those are you plug the advantage core we
have the most accurate shape talk about
why that is in the center okay I think I
heard someone say limits ten minutes
yeah okay good I think this is a good
idea but how do we do them what kinds of
limits would we fall limit of one as X
approaches infinity okay
Oh what what about you let me help you
if you take hopefully this line here
now don't forget you're going to get oh
what a symmetry happening every time you
square something you're going to get
symmetry and I've got two things square
all right so you're gonna expect it
keeps a symmetry right but having the
squares in there makes it hard to work
with the limit because what do you put
in I've got two things a lot more things
right so what am I going to use I'm
gonna rewrite this in a way which will
make it a little easier to see so I'll
make Y the subject okay
I make Y the subject first I suppose I
should multiply through by twelve
there's what I'm working with
so I'll take the limit of them
three x squared my plus plus - I don't
need to do both because one side not one
I'll have the other one interests at
this level - I'm okay what's gonna
happen what can you tell me as X
approaches infinity this question what
will happen to this minus 12 as X
approach infinity what happens to it it
becomes trivial doesn't it because this
guy's becoming millions and billions and
trillions and this guy still minus 12 so
he becomes insignificant so in some
senses I can say this alright we're
gonna have the same limit in the long
run which is what I'm interested in now
that takes actually very easy to work
with
right it's it's a product underneath the
square root so I can break that apart
square root of 3 square root of x
squared
yeah that root 3 is just a constant so
I'll just chuck it out Berbatov squared
of x squared is isn't it cuz it could
never be negative whatever you throw in
there will still be positive
should catch that that's one of the
definitions of everyday
all right so therefore what's this thing
going to look like once you evaluate
this that's just a straight line what's
true 3 it's like 1.7 ish so it's like
it's a steep thing it's gonna look
something like this
notice I'm really interested in this
side because that's the side that I'm
commissioning okay now you can go ahead
and you can do the rest of the limits
okay you can consider what happens to
the negative infinity you can consider
what happens when this has a minus sign
on the front after you go through all
that legwork you will end up getting
beast okay so I have these two
asymptotes that are going to shape my
relation now what
it looks pretty bad but believe it or
not I have all the information I need
okay in fact all everything to do is
draw one pot namely this pot okay and
you can plug in some values to see that
it's gonna happen there are no
stationary points you can see friendship
see what happens but remember how I said
you've got a y squared and an x squared
so you're going to have symmetry across
the x axis sorry that's the y axis but
you're also gonna have symmetry across
the x axis so you take this shape and
you reflect it down and then you take
that [ __ ] back you reflect it across
like so there's my shape icon and this
is what we call this is the last conic
section now some of you are ahead all
the stuff I just did on the board you're
already done the question do you
remember what question I posed to you
after you got a draw yes okay all right
so ten minutes
okay now in case you weren't following
we're trying to think about this
progression this is what we're thinking
about okay
now by the way just as a side note if
some of you were looking at a textbook
you might be like whoa what the hell
already there's still stuff about it
it's just to talk about namely the polar
deficient we will get back to that but
because we're sort of making these
corners I wanted you to see this chain
so you sort of have waiting until the
very end of the topic before you see
what the second is okay now what are
these shows they have names
when x-intercept easy round the special
case of circle it's gonna look something
like that guy okay when extras issues
between nine and one you get the lips so
what happened was if we have vertical
directories it starts to count like sir
okay this shape you getting yes now
you'll notice I'm trying to sideways
rather than upright why because where I
was coming from was having these
vertical direct recedes
right and I had one the other side well
if your directrix brothers only have one
Ford red cheeks is vertical er then your
parabola will be sideways okay from what
we used to now what we got the very last
one we've given a name we call a bonus
okay now my question was why why does it
do this why is it in this order what's
going on you can always see what's
happening don't you